y
[Música]
hola muy buenos días bienvenidos a este
avance informativo en france 24 cierro
el blanco y como siempre un gusto
acompañarlos esta mañana comenzamos en
afganistán donde luego de más de 20 años
de presencia las tropas de eeuu
abandonaron bagram en la mayor base en
ese país tras la retirada de todas las
tropas de eeuu y de la otan las fuerzas
militares de afganistán tomaron el
control de la base aérea las
instalaciones se han usado durante años
para lanzar aviones de ataque contra los
talibanes y otros grupos yihadistas y
llegó a ser el cuartel general de las
tropas de operaciones especiales de eeuu
en este conflicto el proceso de retirada
se viene dando desde mayo y será
completado antes del 11 de septiembre
cuando se cumplen 20 años de los
atentados contra las torres gemelas en
nueva york
y la canciller alemana angela merkel se
reúne con el primer ministro británico
boris johnson en la que será su última
visita al reino unido- antes de dejar su
puesto a finales de este año
merkel llegó a la residencia campestre
de chequers del dirigente conservador
donde hablarán sobre la profundización
de las relaciones entre el reino unido y
alemania- y se prevé que la canciller
dará también un discurso virtual
dirigiéndose al gabinete británico ambos
dirigentes acordaron iniciativas para
expandir los lazos entre sus países
luego la política alemana se reunirá con
la reina isabel 2a
y tras dos semanas de relativa calma
milicianos palestinos causaron tres
incendios que fueron rápidamente
controlados en barrios israelíes
cercanos a la franja de gaza y a los que
israel respondió atacando posiciones de
hamás el ejército israelí aseguró que
aviones de combate atacaron un sitio de
fabricación de armas pertenecientes a
hamás además precisó que este sitio era
utilizado para investigar y desarrollar
armamento si bien el bombardeo de esta
madrugada llega en un momento de
relativa tranquilidad la escalada bélica
del pasado mes de mayo entre israel y
las milicias de gaza aún está viva y el
alto al fuego es aún frágil
el departamento de estado de eeuu
publicó la denominada lista en hiel en
el que aparecen los nombres de 55
políticos de alto rango aparentemente
involucrados en actos de corrupción y
que no podrán acceder a la visa
estadounidense se trata de funcionarios
del salvador honduras y guatemala siete
altos funcionarios salvadoreños están
también en esta lista incluye a más de
una docena de legisladores hondureños y
dos jueces guatemaltecos de alto rango
la reciente publicación de la lista ingo
es una herramienta más para apoyarlos
aurore ellos a construir un futuro
próspero para el savador que nos permite
tomar acción inmediata en contra de
actores que están abusando su poder para
el beneficio personal y la empresa del
ex presidente de eeuu donald trump así
como su director financiero el anway
solberg fueron acusados de hurto mayor
fraude conspiración y falsificación de
documentos como parte de una supuesta
trama de más de 15 años para evadir
impuestos sin embargo tanto la
organización trump como el
su jefe financiero se declararon
inocentes su amplia figura por ahora
entre los imputados y denunció el
proceso como una caza de brujas por
parte de los demócratas
we go away ganaremos este caso pero este
caso nunca debió haberse presentado es
un juicio político
pero los juicios políticos en los que
las personas son blanco de ataques
criminales porque los fiscales están en
desacuerdo con sus políticas ocurren en
países corruptos esto no debe pasar en
eeuu es antiestadounidense al margen y
de esta manera llegamos al final del
avance informativo continuar con
nosotros muy buen día
france24 en español